Good morning, John!
Paternity leave break. What am I doing here?
I pre-recorded this video because I have some things to tell you about VidCon...s. VidCons.
Three of them.
I think my favorite thing about being a YouTube creator is it let's me be on a stage and talk to you in real life.
VidCon is one of the only times of year you get to get together and see each other.
I don't want a TV show! I want to be a pioneer of something brand new.
We should only be sharing our ideas in the environment that enables us to do that the best.
Let go of the ego behind it and focus on what matters, which is reaching the audience.
And nothing enables that like the internet.
[music]
Hank: we come together at VidCon to immerse ourselves in the world of online video.
To connect with our friends and our communities, and to capture and reflect the state of this ever changing
and thriving culture, and simply to celebrate.
We are please to announce the VidCon: US will return to the Anaheim Convention Center
for another exceptional weekend: June 21-24.
And, for the first time ever, VidCon is going global.
VidCon: Europe will kick off April 8-9 in Amsterdam
with VidCon: Australia following on September 9-10 in Melbourne.
These are two cities that foster innovation and collaboration.
They're cosmopolitan, friendly, and lively cities.
And we're very excited to see how VidCon lives and breathes in these new homes.
Tickets are officially available now for VidCon: US.
VidCon: Europe and VidCon: Australia, I hope to see ya there!
[music]
Hank: I am so excited to be going to these things!
I have never been to Amsterdam.
I have never been to the souther hemisphere.
No Australia, no Sydney, no Melbourne, no anything.
I will be at all three: Anaheim, Amsterdam, and Melbourne.
John, you're only gonna be able to be at Anaheim.
So I will just have to be both me and you for those people there, which I think I can pull off.
I've been working on your signature, it's not complicated.
Maybe you can like--you can Skype in for a Dear Hank and John. That'd be fun.
I say without having asked you about that first.
We're digging into the really interesting creator communities in these places,
but we will also be bringing creators from the US and the UK
We're so lucky at VidCon to be able to represent a diversity of creators and creations
and going international is a huge step in that direction for us.
I'm really excited about it. I think it's gonna be a ton of fun.
I apologize to you for coming back from leave temporarily
just to let most of you know about events that you're not gonna be able to be at.
I feel very bad for all the people who live far away from these events, but now there are fewer of you!
For everybody who can come, I'm so excited to see you in Anaheim, Melbourne, and Amsterdam.
John, thank you so much for taking care of this place
and for all of our guest hosts for taking care of this space while I've been gone.
I don't know how it's gone because as I said, I pre-recorded this because I am on leave.
Thanks for not burning the channel down, I assume, and I'll see you on Tuesday.